right about now you might be wondering
whether to get a new iPhone now for some
of you that might be a question of which
new iPhone to get basically should you
get the big new iPhone the iPhone 10's
max or the smallish new iPhone the
iPhone 10s but for others the question
might be whether or not to get a new
iPhone at all considering that over the
past couple of years new iPhones have
crept up to a thousand dollars or more I
mean really what are you getting for
that much money I've been using the new
iPhones for the past five days now on
the inside they have the kind of stuff
that people within the tech sector are
really excited about like the seven
nanometer a12 Bionic chip a super-fast
processor that sets a new industry
standard you also get a great camera and
all of the stuff that living in iOS has
to offer
it takes some really close side-by-side
comparisons to figure out what's new
about these new phones I think a lot of
people won't feel the need to upgrade if
they already bought last year's phone
let's start with the exterior the iPhone
10 s looks exactly like last year's
iPhone 10 they're the same size and this
one has the same 5.8 inch diagonal OLED
display and like last year's phone this
one feels really nice in the hand
although it is slippery and it is prone
to smudges the iPhone 10's Macs on the
other hand is big it's roughly the same
size as last year's iPhone 8 plus but
this one has a 6.5 inch display which
means it has a much greater screen to
body ratio the iPhone 10's max also has
the notch at the top for camera and
depth sensors and just like it's smaller
counterpart it has no home button both
are made of stainless steel and are
coated in what Apple says is a
strengthened more durable glass than on
last year's phone these also come in a
gold finish both of these new phones
have an ip68 waterproof and dustproof
rating which means it's okay to be in
water up to one and a half meters for
about a half hour but this is not
actually new for the industry in LG and
Samsung
have this on their phones as well so if
you're one of those people who are
deciding between two new iPhones then
what you really have to decide is how
big you want to go I mean while this
display is really nice for certain
things it does feel big to me kind of
like the iPhone 8 plus felt once I tried
the iPhone 10 I think for a lot of
people this is the ideal size another
thing to keep in mind about the Mac's
the knotch stands out a lot when you're
using split screen view both of these
phones are said to have improved battery
life but in the case of the iPhone 10s
max it's because it's a physically
bigger phone and it ships with a bigger
battery in the case of the iPhone 10 s
it has about the same battery as last
year's iPhone 10 we were supposed to get
about thirty minutes more per charge in
my experience I didn't really notice the
difference I thought it was pretty much
negligible one thing I did notice was
the new speakers Apple has tweaked both
the hardware and the software on the
speakers to create a wider stereo sound
and they sound pretty great but when it
comes to the new iPhones it's really
what's on the inside that counts the
most important part of the new iPhone
10s and 10's Mac's is the new chip this
is the thing that's going to justify the
cost if anything is going to this new
chip which Apple calls the a12 Bionic is
week 7 nanometre chip with a six-course
CPU for core GPU and an 8 core neural
engine which is the part of the chip
that handles AI stuff what is all of
this mean basically this processor is
supposed to help with everything from
advanced gaming to app switching to AR
apps to apps that use AI and machine
learning the chips neural engine is
available for developers to use now too
so third-party apps are about to get a
lot smarter Apple is pushing for
advances like the Galaga AR game and
this really cool looking home court
basketball analysis app that they showed
off at the phone's watch although when
we tried to get a demo of home core
Apple said the software wasn't ready
the added processing power in this
year's phones plus a larger sensor mean
a better camera and unlike the past few
years when plus sized
iPhones had better cameras than their
smaller counterparts this year's two new
phones have exact
the same camera so there's no
differentiation there now at first
glance a lot of the camera stuff doesn't
seem new Apple already captured HDR
automatically in last year's phones so
why is it calling it smart HDR now and
saying it's new and hasn't bokeh been
around and photography forever trust me
I had all of these thoughts but when I
went out and tested the new camera and
compared it to older iPhones as well as
some other flagship phones I could see
the difference in some of the photos so
we're in a spot right now where there's
a lot of shade but the sky is very
bright the background is very light you
can see bright spots highlights on
buildings so we're looking to see
whether or not things look really blown
out as the camera adjusts for that
lighter exposure or whether it does a
good job of retaining color even as
things brighten in the background and I
have to say overall I think that this
does a better job and overall with
photos than last year's iPhone 10 so you
can definitely see the difference here
the colors are a lot richer if anyone
were to look at this they would say this
is the better photo and then when it
comes to this bokeh effect in portrait
mode you can now adjust the depth after
you've captured a photo Apple says it's
not just isolating the foreground and
then slapping a blur on the background
it says it's recreating the f-stops
to blur things proportionally to how
close they are to the subject let's try
it out
after I capture it you can tap on it hit
edit and then basically you can adjust
the f-stop after the fact which changes
the depth around you know the background
of the photo
this is supposed to be better than the
way that other smartphone makers are
doing this in some cases that seem to be
true but it's still not quite the same
as the bokeh effect you'd get with the
DSLR okay so there are some obvious
differences between this year's new
phones and last year's phones one being
the giant display on the iPhone 10s max
and the new improved processor it's
shipping in both of these phones but
some of the differences are extremely
subtle and that's a good reminder that
this is an X here for iPhones it's
usually a time when we see incremental
internal updates and Apple tries to
convince you that they're totally worth
it if you happen to be ready for an
upgrade and you can afford these phones
you're not going to be unhappy with that
but again if you already have last
year's new phones you probably won't
feel the need to upgrade this year and
that's the thing about having these
amazingly powerful mini computers in our
pockets even if you have a an iPhone
that's a few years older it's still a
pretty darn good smartphone
you
[Music]